sanctions on Iran were put back in place
last night
at midnight maybe maybe early this
morning depending on I guess how late
you stay up these are the exact same
sanctions that were erased in 2015 under
the Iran nuclear deal that was signed
when President Obama was still president
and these sanctions do a few different
things they banned transactions with
Iran that involve dollar banknotes gold
precious metals aluminum steel
commercial passenger planes and coal and
they also stopped imports to the United
States of Iranian carpets and some other
food products and the specific list of
items aside this is a massive
geopolitical blunder by Donald Trump and
we know that Trump has never liked the
Iraq Iran deal mostly or at least
significantly because it has President
Obama's name on it he slammed Obama for
what at this point is years about the
Iran deal but the important thing to
think about is not whether we like
Iran's extremist theocracy because I
don't and no progressive should but the
Iran deal has worked at least to the
extent that Iran hasn't been found to be
in violation of that deal on the terms
that the deal establishes to keep an eye
on what Iran is doing based on the
inspection guidelines that are imposed
by the Iran nuclear deal and we saw as
an example right-wing extremists Israeli
Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu he
tried to make the case I guess it was
some months ago that Iran violated the
deal but it turned out he was citing
evidence from before the deal was signed
not a very strong arming argument for
Iran having violated the deal and
regardless of this Donald Trump
announced in May that he would be
pulling the United States out of the
deal and reimposing those sanctions on
Iran and it is a total unmitigated
disaster for a few different reasons
reason number one if you want to go
after Iran whether it's militarily or
with sanctions there's nothing better
than having a deal in place that they
might violate because if Iran does
violate the deal you
case for pursuing Iran is much stronger
just getting out of the deal and then
going after Iran is not very coherent as
a strategy now I'm not saying I favor
staying in the deal merely so that Iran
violates it and then we bomb Iran that's
not what I'm saying I'm for but what I'm
saying is that it's more valid as a
pretext then I didn't like the Obama
Iran deal so I canceled it and then
sanctioned Iran and potentially as some
people believe Trump wants to do go
after Iran militarily that's reason
number one why getting out of this is a
disaster and putting these sanctions
back on is as much of a disaster number
two it's terrible for the United States
geopolitically to be seen as not
sticking to agreements when other
countries see that even if you sign a
deal with the United States and stick to
it right you don't violate that deal the
next president on completely political
grounds might bail on that deal why
would anyone make deals with countries
that do that that's the second reason
why this is a disaster and then number
three
Trump backing out of the Iran deal and
imposing sanctions on Iran is bad
because it might not only be a step
towards war with Iran it might actually
precipitate it and what I mean by that
is if you are Iran we again we know that
Iran is an unpredictable extremist
theocracy that would love to have
nuclear weapons if you're Iran and the
other side says we're canceling the deal
we're out of the deal even though Iran
didn't violate it doesn't Iran obviously
and immediately go back to developing
nuclear weapons which is supposedly what
we want to prevent them from doing I
don't pretend for a second that Iran is
a great geopolitical ally or a partner
or trustworthy to work with I
acknowledge that they've not to our
awareness violated the deal and that's
good when you unilaterally pull out of a
deal and then you put sanctions on Iran
you're goating them into behaving badly
which realistically is probably what
Trump wants in order to justify war with
Iran if that's the path we believe he's
taking and then this is the key thing
the right is trying to frame people like
me who say we shouldn't pull out of the
deal we shouldn't put the sanctions on
right wants to frame me as someone
friendly to Iranian extremism obviously
anyone who watches this show knows that
that couldn't be more wrong
Iran does lots of horrible things
including supporting Hezbollah and Hamas
and repression of all kinds and much
more but backing out of the deal and
putting in sanctions is likely to have
the opposite effect and push them
towards more radical behavior and then
underlying all of this is the desire by
Trump to push Iran to do something which
will allow him to then do who knows what
and as a reminder remember that Trump
told us in 2013 that Obama was going to
try to find a reason to attack Iran
Trump tweeted in 2013
I predict that President Obama will at
some point attack Iran in order to save
face and even before that in 2011 Donald
Trump tweeted in order to get elected
Barack Obama will start a war with Iran
the political posturing and the
ignorance is significant but it appears
as though what Donald Trump really is
doing here is creating a pretext to do
what he planned to do all along with
Iran predictably so even more made even
more likely by the selection of John
Bolton his national security adviser
yeah I mean I'm not yet totally
convinced that he wants to go to war
with Iran I think maybe this was just an
impulsive decision that he made he after
all did run on pulling out of the Iran
deal he did he seemed to have a very
rudimentary understanding of the whole
thing along with many other things
yeah like when he talked about the 150
billion dollars that we supposedly just
gave to Iran as if that was our money
that we just handed them over as a
president not explaining that that was
you know Iranian US assets for a longest
time was that the story of when he
claimed that it was a cash handed over
on a tarmac off private that was
something he would repeat over and over
in campaign speeches and fact checkers
would show that it's just not true
so bottom line would anybody be shocked
if as soon as the US is out of the deal
Iran starts a rich in uranium again of
course not any rational country
understanding why it's better for them
to have nukes than not to have them in a
sort of vacuum would immediately start
doing that and then Trump could
potentially use that to go after Iran
absolute total geopolitical blunder on
less you want war with Iran in which
case it's exactly what you should be
doing and Donald Trump is doing that but
our allies aren't impotent in their
ability to respond to this and that's
where I want to go next with the Iran
story